oh just say yes to the dress good  morning everyone I apologize for the  late / no upload my camera equipment  what is that probably working not  probably working not properly working  both are correct today decided to do  something a little new I want to do an  ode to video 0 to l know hi Connor I'm  in a hotel right now because we're  shooting more of hashtag hey USA go  check it out youtube.com slash  astronauts planted TV here's a spoiler  dafuq is that in this hotel that we're  staying right now currently is one of my  favorite amenities that is complimentary  breakfast so today I want to make a  video called ode to complimentary  breakfast  you  they go there the ode to a complimentary  breakfast I don't know Greece's  guidebook com youtube.com slash Ashley  us want a TV and a heart come / book  sincerely don't know  so deadly so coffee on myself but you uh  sir here